[Music]
rihanna is glowing at
gucci work work work work work
the singer shows everyone she can still
work it while pregnant stepping out with
beau asap rocky for the italian fashion
house's latest show in milan rihanna's
baby bump front and center as riri rocks
a black latex top paired with an
egyptian inspired headdress statement
necklaces and a lavender fur coat as for
the rapper he sports an all-black
ensemble accessorized with a large gucci
suitcase after making a stop on the
carpet the couple stepped inside the
event into this mirror-filled pink room
[Music]
rocky and reese seemed to be the center
of everyone's attention and who can
blame them the grammy winners turned her
pregnancy into a total fashion show
check out rhee on the red carpet just a
couple weeks ago she's stunned in a
green sequin halter top while
celebrating her fenty brands you are
making it look so stylish
you're having fun with it well you have
to right see that i mean so it's a long
nine to ten months girl you know you you
have to enjoy it asap was also by her
side it was the first time the two
attended a public event together since
announcing they're expecting their first
child i'm trying to enjoy it as much as
i could and fashion is one of my
favorite things so
you know redefining what it means to
even be
pregnant and maternal you know it always
it it can get uncomfortable at times so
you know you can dress the part and
pretend well there's no pretending when
it comes to this musical duo feels with
the baby on the way she may never wear
it but she save it so our babies will be
fire than their parents earlier this
month a source told e.t the two are so
happy adding that rihanna has always
wanted to be a mother and have children
and she thinks asap is going to be the
best dad what are you looking forward to
as you move into a new chapter of your
life asap i'm just excited for what i
don't know yet you know everything is
new to me so
you know i'm excited
how are you keeping track of the
milestones as the two of you go through
this journey together
i mean i'm just living
so what has we been loving most about
pregnancy uh donuts so far
that's a plus two but for reals it's all
an exciting journey so far i'm just
taking it as it comes every week it's
something new
and i'm just taking it i'm enjoying it
and while fans might think rihanna
becoming a mama means music is taking a
back seat she says the navy has nothing
to worry about yes you're still going to
get music from me maybe a lullaby i can
see you and asap dropping demos in the
studio oh my goodness not a lullaby my
fans would kill me they waited this long
for a lullaby i'd never sleep with this
music they're like we are grown until
then we'll just keep soaking up riri
slaying all the looks
[Music]